was it aggravating for you during covet
that you couldn't perform or did you
welcome the rest
it was kind of aggravating uh part of it
was aggravating part of it was very
enjoyable because i got to be home with
my kids for a long time i got to know
them i got to hang out with them which
you know at my age to have young
children is a totally different thing
than when you're young younger
um on the other side not exhausting it's
not exhausting it's exhausting
yes totally examined grandfather age i
take my kids to school and other parents
oh your grandchildren are beautiful
yeah
shut up right yeah no it's okay yeah i
mean coming to that age during covid you
guys paid your band you paid them for
the whole what year or two that you were
off the road well i i did pay them full
salary for a year
uh i
have a great band i'm so happy to have
them on stage i'm so happy that
they stay with me when i go out and i do
gigs i don't do as many gigs as i used
to do
but there they are
um
and i back in the day when i had some
money issues i wasn't able to take care
of the band the same way i am now
right um i wasn't able to compensate
them and
uh i wanted to take care of the band
because musicians really took it on the
chin they couldn't we couldn't work we
couldn't perform we couldn't appear
anywhere we couldn't get jobs we were
like one of the last people on the totem
pole i think after sports figures
right uh we had to wait for all these
venues to open and clear people to get
in it's still
up in the air whether a lot of these
venues are going to be available to us
or not whether people are going to wear
masks whether there's a vaccine passport
uh we're still waiting on some venues to
see if we're going to be able to work or
not so it's called the coffee yeah the
concert you have coming up at the garden
though that's that you got to be vast
right to get in yes uh i assume you want
that i mean uh enough at least double
vaccine
right and and uh and and that's the very
least do you have to do that that
there's
there's a lot of ifs it's very very iffy
it still is and this variant has thrown
a monkey wrench into the whole thing